It happened nine months ago in Georgia.
这件事发生在九个月前的乔治亚州。
I was at work. And I ate a Reese's cup, which is what I usually eat. And I don't know. I just felt really sick immediately.
当时我在上班，像往常一样吃了一杯Reese's巧克力杯。我也不知道怎么回事，吃完立刻感觉非常不舒服。
Taylor was pretty sure-- not totally sure, but pretty sure. It was the same with Kae in Ohio. She suspected, but it was confusing.
泰勒当时很确定——虽然不是百分之百确定，但大概率是有了。俄亥俄州的凯也是一样的情况。她有所怀疑，但当时很困惑。
Yeah. Yeah, I had COVID the same time. So it was just like, is it COVID? Is it not? I had a little bit of nausea. But honestly, I just chalked it up to not really feeling the best.
是的。没错，我当时刚好感染了新冠。所以我就在想，是新冠导致的吗？还是别的？我有一点恶心。但老实说，我只是把它归结为自己没休息好。
Ashley in Texas, she was nauseous too. But her kids had just had a stomach bug.
德克萨斯州的阿什莉也感到恶心。但她的孩子刚好得了肠胃炎。
And so I had been feeling sick, but then everyone else felt better. And come the morning of Fourth of July, I just threw up so hard. I don't know if this is too much information, but I wasn't puking out my food from last night. I didn't have stomach poisoning. I was dry heaving. It was a pregnancy, hormonal, morning-sickness puking, which, if you've puked for entire pregnancies before, it's very specific.
我一直觉得不舒服，但其他人很快就好转了。到了七月四号那天早上，我吐得非常厉害。不知道这算不算透露太多细节，但我吐出来的不是昨晚吃的食物。我没有食物中毒。我是在干呕。那是怀孕带来的荷尔蒙引起的晨吐，如果你之前经历过整个孕期的呕吐，就会知道那种感觉非常特别。
Katie was one of many women whose boyfriends insisted on multiple tests. Her boyfriend did not believe it.
凯蒂是众多男友坚持要求多做几次测试的女性之一。她的男友不相信结果。
When he saw it, he was like, no, it could be wrong. Take another one. Take another one. It could be wrong. And it was one of the digital ones, so it wasn't like we read the lines wrong or anything. It was a digital one, and it came back quick. I was like, there's no way it's wrong.
当他看到结果时，他说，不，这可能是错的。再测一次。再测一次。这可能是错的。而且那还是数字测试笔，不像那种看杠数的，不存在看错的问题。那是数字显示的结果，很快就出来了。我说，这绝对不可能出错。
It wasn't wrong. She was pregnant. They were all pregnant. And they all did not want to be pregnant. But they all lived in states that had just banned abortion. Taylor in Georgia.
确实没出错。她怀孕了。她们都怀孕了。而且她们都不想怀孕。但她们都住在刚禁止堕胎的州。乔治亚州的泰勒也是如此。
I was very naive about it. Because I had totally forgot-- I think Roe v. Wade was maybe in May.
我对此非常天真。因为我完全忘了——我想“罗诉韦德案”的推翻可能是在五月份。
It was June. The Supreme Court overturned Roe v. Wade, the ruling that made abortion a constitutional right. That happened the week before Taylor got pregnant.
是六月。最高法院推翻了“罗诉韦德案”，那项裁决曾将堕胎定为宪法权利。那是泰勒怀孕前一周发生的事。
Yeah. So it was new, but it also wasn't something that was important to me on the regular day to day so I got on the phone and I called. And they were super rude to me at Planned Parenthood. I was like, well, I don't even think I'm 6 weeks. And I really wasn't understanding what she was saying because she was saying it doesn't really matter. We're just not going to be able to do it.
对。所以这件事很新鲜，但平时我也没怎么把它当回事。于是我打了电话。计划生育协会的人对我的态度非常粗鲁。我说，好吧，我觉得我还没到6周。我真的没听懂她在说什么，因为她说这不重要，他们就是没法帮我做手术。
And that's when I was like, oh. I totally forgot that this is this new thing where I can't go and get it done. I have to go somewhere else.
就在那一刻我意识到，哦，我完全忘了这是一项新政策，我没法去那边做了，我得去别的地方。
Kae in Ohio was also looking for a clinic. She started calling immediately.
俄亥俄州的凯也在寻找诊所。她立刻开始打电话。
They didn't have anything for-- I think it was a month or two. And, yeah, it was so backed up. And it was like that pretty much everywhere I had checked. It was either a few weeks to a couple of months.
他们什么安排都没有——我想得等一两个月。是的，排队非常满。我查过的地方几乎都是这样。要么排几周，要么排几个月。
They'd have to wait. It's been nine months since the Supreme Court overturned Roe v. Wade. And to mark that fact, on today's show, we're going to look at what these last nine months have been like for people who discovered they were pregnant right when the laws changed in their states. They came up against a wall trying to find an abortion. These are people who, nine months ago, found themselves waiting for an appointment, waiting to get together money to travel, to make a plan, just to get somebody on the phone.
她们只能等。距离最高法院推翻“罗诉韦德案”已经过去九个月了。为了纪念这个节点，在今天的节目中，我们将看看过去这九个月里，那些在州法律刚变动时就发现自己怀孕的人经历了什么。她们在寻找堕胎途径时碰了壁。这些人九个月前发现自己身处困境：等着预约，等着凑钱去外地，等着制定计划，甚至只是为了能打通一个咨询电话。
And in that waiting, there was time for other things to happen. For instance, Kae in Ohio and Taylor in Georgia were both waiting for an appointment. And one day, Kae and her boyfriend walked to Dairy Queen.
在等待的过程中，还有其他事情发生。比如，在俄亥俄州的凯和在乔治亚州的泰勒都在等待预约。有一天，凯和她的男友去了冰雪皇后餐厅（Dairy Queen）。
It wasn't until the walk back that we started to talk about it. And we were both kind of joking about the fact that, oh, I wonder what our baby would look like. And so we were like discussing like, oh, what color eyes do you think they would have? What color hair?
直到回来的路上，我们才开始讨论这件事。我们俩还开玩笑说，哦，真好奇我们的孩子会长什么样。于是我们就讨论，哦，你觉得他们会有什么颜色的眼睛？什么颜色的头发？
We got to talking about what we were like as kids. And then we were like, yeah, that could be fun to have our own. I was watching us talk about how we were. And I was like, yeah, that would be awesome to have a baby with this person. Talking through it, I was like, oh my gosh, am I changing my mind? Am I going to keep it?
我们开始谈论自己小时候是什么样。然后我们就觉得，是啊，有自己的孩子可能会很有趣。我看着我们谈论彼此的样子，心想，是的，能和这个人有孩子真是太棒了。在谈论的过程中，我在想，天哪，我是不是改变主意了？我打算生下来吗？
Taylor started wondering the same thing. She'd been certain until she waited, first for the ultrasound appointment and then for the abortion. It was weeks and weeks.
泰勒也开始有同样的想法。在等待超声波预约和堕胎的过程中，她一直很坚定，但时间被拉长到了几周又几周。
I just spent a lot of time thinking what I wanted, if I felt like-- do I want to have a kid or not? I think it was the first time-- for someone like me who's very sure of themselves, that was the first time I was ever stumped.
我花了很多时间思考我想要什么，思考我是否真的——我想要个孩子还是不想要？我想这对我这样一直非常有主见的人来说，是第一次感到如此困惑。
If Kae and Taylor had been pregnant weeks earlier, they both would have gotten abortions at nearby clinics. But now this new reality set them both on very different paths as they tried to find their way to an abortion. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, Nine Months after the end of Roe v. Wade.
如果凯和泰勒早几周怀孕，她们本可以在附近的诊所堕胎。但现在，新的现实让她们在寻求堕胎的过程中走上了截然不同的道路。这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》节目。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是：罗诉韦德案终结后的九个月。
Today's episode was inspired by the excellent reporting of Caroline Kitchener, who covers abortion for the Washington Post. If you've ever seen her stories, Caroline's reporting just gets inside people's lives in this way that feels very unusual, intimate and very real, and you see how not black and white people's feelings and situations can be. She'll be with us for the hour. Stay with us, OK?
今天的节目灵感来自《华盛顿邮报》负责堕胎议题的杰出记者卡罗琳·基奇纳的报道。如果你看过她的故事，卡罗琳的报道总是能以一种不同寻常、亲密且真实的方式深入人们的生活，让你看到人们的情感和处境并非非黑即白。她将陪伴我们度过这一小时。请留下来，好吗？
First trimester. So we start today's show in those first few months right after the Court's decision and how this played out for Kae and Taylor, who had both just found out they were pregnant and both wanted abortions. 14 states have banned most abortions since Roe was overturned. And for some people, that's it. They won't get abortions. But others, of course, like Kae and Taylor, they're still going to try to get one. And for them, the state bans are a hurdle that slows things down as they try to figure out how.
第一孕期。我们今天从法院裁决后的最初几个月开始，看看凯和泰勒是如何经历这一切的，她们都刚发现自己怀孕并想要堕胎。自从“罗案”被推翻后，14个州禁止了大多数堕胎行为。对一些人来说，这就是终点，她们无法堕胎。但当然，像凯和泰勒这样的人，还是会尝试。对她们来说，州的禁令是一个减慢她们行动速度的障碍，她们在试图找出解决办法。
The anti-abortion movement is aware that there's this new window of time where maybe they could reach these people and persuade them to change their minds. Since the fall of Roe, there's been a big push to do just that, to increase state funding for crisis pregnancy centers, which already get millions of dollars from taxpayers. These are clinics whose whole mission is to convince people to not get abortions.
反堕胎运动意识到，现在出现了一个新的窗口期，或许他们可以接触到这些人并说服她们改变主意。自“罗案”倒台以来，他们一直在大力推动这一进程，增加对危机怀孕中心的州政府拨款，而这些中心本就已经从纳税人那里获得了数百万美元。这些诊所的全部使命就是说服人们不要堕胎。
Meanwhile, online, anti-abortion folks are trying to connect with people who are looking for information about abortions. An anti-abortion activist reached both Kae and Taylor during the first trimesters. And each responded very differently. Caroline Kitchener watched this unfold for each of them in two separate states, week by week.
与此同时，在网上，反堕胎人士正试图与那些寻找堕胎信息的人取得联系。一名反堕胎活动人士在凯和泰勒的孕早期分别接触了她们。两人的反应截然不同。卡罗琳·基奇纳在两个不同的州，逐周观察了这一切的展开。
Just a quick note that we've changed some names in today's show for people who requested that for privacy, though Kae and Taylor are their real names. Anyway, here's Caroline.
简单提一下，为了保护隐私，我们更改了今天节目中部分人的名字，但凯和泰勒是她们的真实名字。总之，有请卡罗琳。
Kae was in Ohio. Taylor was in Georgia. Both states had just banned abortion after six weeks of pregnancy. That leaves a super short window to get an abortion.
凯在俄亥俄州，泰勒在乔治亚州。这两个州都刚刚禁止了怀孕六周后的堕胎。这留给她们寻求堕胎的时间非常短。
From the beginning, Kate tried to approach her pregnancy the way she approaches other things in her life. She's methodical, organized. Kae is 25 years old, white, owns her own pet-sitting business.
从一开始，凯就试图用对待生活中其他事情的方式来处理怀孕这件事。她做事很有条理、很有计划。凯今年25岁，白人，经营着自己的宠物寄养生意。
She kept track of her periods on an app. And when she missed one, she took a pregnancy test. It was positive. She started calling clinics to try to get an appointment for an abortion. Kae wasn't completely sure she wanted one. Ever since that walk with her boyfriend to the Dairy Queen, she'd started going back and forth, wondering if maybe she should keep the pregnancy after all. She made a pro/con list. She really wasn't sure.
她在应用程序上记录月经周期，当发现没来时，她做了验孕棒测试。结果是阳性。她开始打电话给诊所预约堕胎。凯并不完全确定自己想要堕胎。自从和男友去冰雪皇后的那次散步后，她开始犹豫不决，怀疑自己是否应该把孩子生下来。她列了一张利弊清单，确实拿不定主意。
Her boyfriend kept telling her that he'd support her no matter what. That wasn't exactly helpful. She pressed him, trying to figure out what he actually thought.
男友一直告诉她，无论她做什么决定都会支持她。这并没有什么帮助。她追问他，想弄清楚他到底是怎么想的。
Because I was like, well, OK, I'm making up my mind. I'm going to have an abortion. How do you feel about that? That's fine. OK. Well, I changed my mind and now I'm thinking about keeping it. How do you feel about that? That's fine. And I was like, dude, what the hell? Come on, give me something more.
因为我说，好吧，我已经下定决心了。我打算堕胎。你觉得怎么样？他说，没关系。好吧。我说，我改变主意了，现在考虑生下来。你觉得怎么样？他说，没关系。我当时就想，老兄，搞什么鬼？拜托，给我点具体的建议。
It was just kind of like wanting almost, like, somebody to tell me what to do because I felt so out of control of the situation that like I just needed somebody, almost, to help me make the decision.
我几乎就是希望有人能告诉我该怎么做，因为我感觉自己对局势失去了控制，我非常需要有人帮我做决定。
Finally, Kae found a Women's Center online that offered free ultrasounds and abortion consultations. They had an appointment right away.
最终，凯在网上找到了一家女性中心，提供免费超声波检查和堕胎咨询。他们立刻就给安排了预约。
I remember my first thought was like, wow, this is super purple.
我记得我的第一个想法是，哇，这地方紫色得过分了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
What was purple?
什么东西是紫色的？
Pretty much everything-- the walls, some of the decor. I just remember it was very calming and quiet. I remember them offering me ginger ale. And I was just like, yeah, I'll take ginger ale. I'm super nauseous.
几乎所有东西——墙壁，还有一些装饰。我只记得那里非常安静平和。我记得他们给了我姜汁汽水。我说，好吧，我要姜汁汽水。我恶心得厉害。
The Women's Center was actually a crisis pregnancy center. Those are places where staff are specially trained to talk people out of having abortions. But Kae didn't know any of that. She was there to get an answer to a question. Could she get an abortion in Ohio at all? Was she still under six weeks? The crisis pregnancy center gave her an ultrasound.
这家女性中心实际上是一家危机怀孕中心。这些地方的工作人员受过专门训练，专门负责说服人们不要堕胎。但凯对此一无所知。她只是去那里寻找答案：她在俄亥俄州还能堕胎吗？她还在六周以内吗？危机怀孕中心为她做了超声波检查。
I was like, OK, well, how far along am I? And they were like, too early to even tell. It's too early to say anything.
我说，好的，那我怀孕多久了？他们说，现在太早了，没法确定。什么都说不了。
A trained ultrasound tech should have been able to give her some sense of how far along she was starting around five weeks, which is right where Kae thought she was.
训练有素的超声波技师通常在五周左右就能给出大致的孕期判断，而这正是凯认为自己所处的阶段。
Obviously, I'm not a doctor so I'm not going to argue argue with somebody. But I was looking at it. I'm like, there's nothing you can tell me, absolutely nothing? And I was just like, is there anything, any type of estimate? And she was like, I can't say. We'll just have to reschedule another ultrasound about a week from now. The only thing that kept going through my head was I'm going to be past six weeks.
显然，我不是医生，所以我不打算和别人争论。但我看了屏幕，心想，你真的什么都看不出来吗？一点点都看不出来？我问，有没有任何估计？她说，我没法说。我们得下周再预约一次超声波。我脑子里唯一转的就是：到时候我就超过六周了。
Here is something I've heard from abortion providers. Crisis pregnancy centers will sometimes delay telling people how far along they are-- or they'll misinform people about how far along they are-- until abortion is no longer an option. The doctors tell me they've heard this from patients who come in to see them after going to a pregnancy center. Kae had wanted someone to help her decide what to do with this pregnancy, and she'd walked into a place that was specifically set up to do just that.
这是我从堕胎服务提供者那里听到的情况。危机怀孕中心有时会延迟告诉人们孕周——或者会提供错误的信息——直到堕胎不再是一个可行的选择。医生们告诉我，他们从去过这些中心后转诊而来的病人那里听说过这种情况。凯本来是想找人帮她决定如何处理这个孩子，却走进了一个专门为了阻碍她做出堕胎决定而设立的地方。
Meanwhile, Taylor could not get an abortion in Georgia because she was too far along. She had to fly to Florida for her appointment, but the soonest one she could get was weeks away. Taylor is 27 years old, Black. She studied film in college, ended up working an office job at a financial services company. She just got in her first apartment.
与此同时，泰勒因为孕周太长，在乔治亚州无法堕胎。她不得不飞往佛罗里达州去预约，但最快也要几周之后。泰勒今年27岁，黑人。她在大学学的是电影，最后在一家金融服务公司做文职工作。她刚搬进自己的第一间公寓。
Also, she's a little bit nerdy, big Reddit user. When she hears something that piques her interest, her first move is usually to scout around for the relevant subreddit. So when she learned that her abortion procedure would use a suction tool, Taylor wanted to know more.
而且，她有点书呆子气，是Reddit的大用户。当她听到引起兴趣的东西时，第一反应通常是去搜索相关的子版块（subreddit）。所以当她了解到自己的堕胎手术会使用吸取工具时，泰勒想了解更多。
I actually went home and looked it up. Because I think a lot of times, the only images we have are of people who are pro-life, who want to show you pieces of gutted fetuses. So I didn't look up anything like that. But I was able to see an animated version of what it looks like when the actual surgical tool is in the body and it pulls the fetus out.
我实际上回家查了查。因为我觉得很多时候，我们看到的唯一影像来自反堕胎人士，他们想让你看那些被切碎的胎儿残骸。我没有查那种图片，但我查到了手术工具进入体内将胎儿吸出的动画演示。
A tube would be inserted inside her uterus, a pump, and then the suction.
一根管子会被插入子宫，加上吸泵，然后进行抽吸。
And it made me wonder if the kid was alive or not and if it's going to hurt him if they use that tool. I just thought that there would be a more advanced way to do it that wouldn't be that gruesome. And it made me wonder if it's too barbaric or too archaic or too violent.
这让我怀疑孩子当时是否活着，如果使用那种工具会不会伤害到他。我原以为会有更先进、不那么可怕的方法。这让我怀疑这是否过于野蛮、古老或暴力。
Taylor had pretty uncomplicated feelings about abortion up until now. To the extent she'd ever thought about it, she always figured that if she did get pregnant unexpectedly, she'd go to the Planned Parenthood clinic down the road from her apartment, and that would be that. But now, she wasn't sure what to do. She called her aunt, and she said--
在此之前，泰勒对堕胎的感受非常简单。在某种程度上，如果她真的意外怀孕，她一直以为自己会去公寓附近的计划生育诊所，然后就把事情解决了。但现在，她不确定该怎么办。她打电话给姨妈，姨妈说——
I don't know if I'm comfortable doing this. And she was just like, listen, you cannot afford a kid. That's just the end of the day. It doesn't matter if you think the procedure is barbaric. They do it every day. This is a very common procedure. This is not anything you need to be alarmed about. You'll be just fine.
我不知道自己是否有心理准备去做这个。她只是说，听着，你负担不起孩子。归根结底就是这样。不管你认为这个手术是否野蛮，他们每天都在做。这是一种非常普遍的手术。这不是你需要惊慌的事情。你会没事的。
Her aunt reminded her that she didn't have a lot of savings. Her new job wasn't a done deal. She still had to pass a big exam to keep it. And she didn't know how to drive. Taylor says it was kind of insulting.
姨妈提醒她，她没什么积蓄。新工作还没完全稳下来。她还得通过一项大考才能保住职位。而且她不会开车。泰勒说这听起来有点伤人。
She called her boyfriend. They were long distance. He had just moved to Florida, and the clinic she'd picked for the abortion was near where he lived. Now, on the phone, she told him she was having doubts. He assured her that was totally normal. And he had his own theory to explain her feelings.
她打电话给男友。他们是异地恋。他刚搬到佛罗里达，泰勒选的堕胎诊所就在他家附近。电话里，她告诉他自己有疑虑。他向她保证这很正常，并提出了一个解释她这种感受的理论。
What he was saying was that he felt like, because he was so far away, maybe the baby was a way for me to feel more connected to him. Then I was just like, what the-- I just immediately was like, you're not that important to me. I think I'm pretty sure I'm still in control of how I feel. If I was having second thoughts, it would 100% be because of me and no one else.
他说的是，他觉得因为他离得那么远，也许孩子是让我感觉到与他更亲密的一种方式。我立刻就回击说，去你的，你对我没那么重要。我很确定我依然能掌控自己的感受。如果我有二心，那百分之百是因为我个人，而不是因为别人。
You know, a baby is not something that you use to feel closer to another person. It was just such a weird thing to even suggest, me wanting to emotionally connect with him through the baby. And that's when I went out for other people's opinions.
你知道，孩子不是让你用来拉近与另一个人距离的东西。他提出这个建议真是太奇怪了，说我因为想在情感上与他连接而想要留下孩子。就在那时，我开始寻求其他人的意见。
Taylor found herself in the exact same spot as Kae in Ohio, asking other people what she should do. Like Kae, Taylor would soon find herself face to face with the anti-abortion movement, people who were ready and eager to influence her decision.
泰勒发现自己处境和俄亥俄州的凯完全一样，都在问别人她该怎么办。像凯一样，泰勒很快也会发现自己面对的是反堕胎运动，那些准备好且渴望影响她决定的人。
When Kae left her appointment at the pregnancy center in Ohio, she still didn't know it wasn't a regular, abortion-friendly medical clinic. The staff handed her a gift bag. It had a nail file, many, many pamphlets, spearmint gum to help with nausea, and prenatal vitamins, which she did think was a little bit weird. She'd told them that she was planning to get an abortion.
当凯离开俄亥俄州那个怀孕中心时，她依然不知道那不是一家正规的、支持堕胎的医疗诊所。工作人员给了她一个礼品袋。里面有一个指甲锉、许多许多宣传册、用来缓解恶心的薄荷口香糖，还有产前维生素，她觉得这点很奇怪。她明明告诉过他们她打算堕胎。
It was the way that they described them that made me think that they weren't completely listening to me. Because they were like, well, this is for the health of your pregnancy, moving forward. And, well, the pregnancy isn't moving forward.
正是他们描述维生素的方式让我觉得他们根本没在听我说话。他们说，这是为了你怀孕后的健康着想。可是，怀孕根本就不会继续下去了。
Having somebody give me these options and almost push the option I wanted to the side like it wasn't even really like a choice, that really just irked me. And I was like, well, this is what I want, and you're not even listening to me. I would expect this from a man or something, but to have other women disregard what I was saying was one of the most irritating things to me.
让别人给我提供这些选择，甚至把我想要的选项推到一边，表现得那好像根本就不是一个选择，这真的惹恼了我。我心想，这才是我的意愿，而你们甚至没在听。如果是男人这样对我，我可能还会预料到，但看到同为女性的人忽视我的话，这是最让我愤怒的事情之一。
Crisis pregnancy centers have carefully thought through all these moves to push people away from abortion. But for Kae, it actually seemed like it was backfiring. It was making her more sure that she wanted an abortion. When she left, she looked up abortion pills online and found Aid Access, an organization based in Europe that sends pills to all 50 states, even states where abortion is banned. They operate in this kind of legal gray area. That made Kae nervous, but she put in the order anyway.
危机怀孕中心精心设计了所有这些手段来阻碍人们堕胎。但对凯来说，这似乎适得其反。这让她更坚定了堕胎的决心。离开后，她在网上查询了堕胎药，找到了Aid Access，一个总部设在欧洲的组织，他们向所有50个州发送药物，即使是堕胎违法的州。他们运营在一种法律灰色地带。这让凯很紧张，但她还是下了订单。
She still wanted to know how far along she was, so she went back for another scan at the crisis pregnancy center. People who work at crisis pregnancy centers, they see their work as saving lives. That's what they're there for. I talked to several staffers at centers who told me they find immense fulfillment in convincing even just one person to keep their pregnancy. And part of that is making the best case they can for not having an abortion.
她仍然想知道自己怀孕多久了，所以她又去了一次危机怀孕中心做检查。在危机怀孕中心工作的人，视自己的工作为拯救生命。这就是他们在那里的原因。我采访了几位中心的工作人员，他们告诉我，只要能说服一个人留下孩子，他们就感到巨大的成就感。而这的一部分就是尽他们所能为“不堕胎”提供最有力的论据。
Kae got on the ultrasound table for a second time. They asked if she wanted pictures, no, thank you, she said. They played her something they called a heartbeat. Technically, doctors say, this is not a heartbeat. Kae did not want to hear it.
凯第二次躺上了超声波检查台。他们问她要不要照片，她说不，谢谢。他们播放了据称是“心跳”的声音。从技术上讲，医生们表示这根本不是心跳。凯不想听。
I hadn't changed my mind. Hearing that was just another sound for me. And the ultrasound tech, who knew that I did not want to keep this pregnancy, asked me if I wanted to take pictures home with me. And I immediately was just like, no, I don't want that. And she was just like, well, are you sure? I was like, yeah, pretty sure.
我并没有改变主意。听到那个声音对我来说也只是另一种噪音。而那位知道我不想留下孩子的超声波技师，问我想不想把照片带回家，我立刻说，不，我不要。她还说，你确定吗？我说，是，我很确定。
I was already angry. And then having her question me, I was just like, you guys really just aren't getting this. Again, are you sure you don't want pictures? And I was like, yes, I am very sure. I plan on getting an abortion still. I got my pills from Aid Access. I bought those. I'm just waiting for those to get to my house. She immediately just had this change of demeanor to being completely defensive. And that--
我本来就已经很生气了。被她反复追问，我心想，你们这群人真是不可理喻。她又问，你确定不要照片吗？我说，是的，非常确定。我依然计划堕胎。我已经从Aid Access买到了药。我买了那些药。我只是在等快递送到我家。她的态度立刻变了，变得极具防卫性。而那——
In what way, when you say defensive?
当你说是防卫性时，指的是什么方面？
Her first thing was, oh, well, you should be careful because you never know what kind of grade pill you're going to get.
她第一反应是，噢，那你得小心点，因为你根本不知道你会买到什么级别的劣质药。
To be clear, there's no such thing as different grade abortion pills. And Aid Access has been around for years and is a widely-trusted source. The crisis pregnancy center told Kae how far along she was, six weeks and three days.
澄清一下，根本不存在堕胎药级别这一说。Aid Access已经存在多年，是一个被广泛信任的来源。最后，危机怀孕中心告诉凯她怀孕多久了：六周零三天。
That meant a couple of things. First, Kae could have tried to get an abortion in a clinic in Ohio right after her last appointment, had she known. It also meant that the week before, a trained sonographer should have been able to give her some sense of how far along she was.
这意味着几件事。首先，如果她知道的话，凯本来可以在上次预约后尝试在俄亥俄州的诊所堕胎。这也意味着，前一周，训练有素的超声波技师本来是可以给出大致孕周的。
With Kae's permission, I reached out to the Women's Center. It's called Bella Women's Center. They wouldn't give me an interview, but they said in a statement that they don't talk about individual patients because of confidentiality. They did say they are aware of the timeline pressure that comes with a six-week abortion ban. And they added that they are committed to, quote, "full disclosure of the patient's options."
在凯的允许下，我联系了那家女性中心，名字叫贝拉女性中心（Bella Women's Center）。他们拒绝接受采访，但在声明中表示，由于保密协议，他们不讨论个别病人。他们确实表示，他们意识到六周堕胎禁令带来的时间压力。他们还补充说，他们致力于“向患者充分披露所有选择”。
But as far as Kae was concerned, her options were dwindling. Kae wanted to take the abortion pills by the time she was 10 weeks pregnant because that's what the FDA advises. She was probably right around six weeks, and the pills could take up to a month to be delivered. She was running out of time.
但就凯而言，她的选择正在缩减。凯希望在怀孕10周之前服用堕胎药，因为那是FDA建议的期限。她当时大概在六周左右，而药物寄送可能需要一个月。她的时间不多了。
Meanwhile, in Georgia, while Taylor waited, she fixated on one particular question. She couldn't find a satisfying answer, no matter how many people she talked to or how much research she did online. Would the abortion hurt the baby?
与此同时，在乔治亚州，泰勒在等待期间，一直纠结于一个特定问题。无论她询问了多少人，无论她在网上做了多少研究，她都找不到一个让她满意的答案：堕胎会伤害孩子吗？
And the only people who have ever said abortions actually physically hurt babies are people who are pro-life.
而且唯一声称堕胎会实际上伤害婴儿的人，都是反堕胎人士。
She found an anti-abortion forum online and wrote a public message.
她在网上找到了一个反堕胎论坛，并写了一条公开消息。
OK. Hi. OK, let me not. Hi, I'm pro-choice, weirdly having second thoughts about my appointment next week. Advice, question mark, question mark.
好的。嗨。好吧，让我别发这个。嗨，我是支持堕胎选择的，很奇怪地对下周的预约有了二心。求建议，疑问号，疑问号。
She writes that she is now 11 weeks pregnant.
她写道自己现在怀孕11周了。
I've just gotten used to being pregnant, and I have to fly to another state to get an abortion.
我已经习惯了怀孕的状态，而且我不得不飞到另一个州去堕胎。
And then what happened?
然后发生了什么？
A lot of people commented on that post, just like, flooding. A lot of them were telling me I could give my baby away for adoption. Any option is better to them than to "murder," quote, unquote, your baby.
那篇帖子的评论区挤满了人。很多人告诉我可以把孩子送去领养。对他们来说，任何选项都比“谋杀”你的孩子要好。
Anti-abortion advocates online use all sorts of different strategies to sway people away from abortion, to do everything they can to ensure that pregnancies are carried to term.
网上的反堕胎人士使用各种不同的策略来动摇人们的想法，尽一切可能确保妊娠足月生产。
I actually had this lady ask me if I would do an open adoption.
甚至有个女士问我是否愿意做开放式收养。
Oh, wow, like, to give it to her.
噢，哇，你是说把孩子给她？
Right.
对。
How did you feel about that?
你对此有什么感觉？
There's no way I would do that. I think it was probably a little over 200 comments. People were offering me money. People were just super involved in making sure I didn't go to my appointment.
我绝不可能那么做。我想大概有200多条评论。人们主动提出给我钱。人们非常热衷于确保我不去参加预约。
How did it feel to read those things?
阅读这些东西是什么感觉？
There's always a tone of coercion, in my opinion. But it was nice to read them because you just want to hear other people's opinions. So just hearing that, it was nice to hear the other side of it versus just, like, the answer is the abortion. But I had no one else that was actually excited for me. Because I will say that in the moment, I really needed somebody to connect with me about how I was feeling.
在我看来，总有一种胁迫的语气。但阅读它们感觉不错，因为你只想听听别人的看法。所以听到那些话，能听到另一方面的意见，而不是只有“答案就是堕胎”这一种声音，这很好。但我身边没人能真正对我的感受感同身受。因为我必须说，在那一刻，我非常需要有人与我建立联系，理解我的感受。
When I first started talking to Kae and Taylor, it looked to me like they could be swayed by people who desperately wanted to sway them. Kae was trying out different decisions, auditioning them for her boyfriend. And Taylor was seeking out guidance from people she didn't even know.
当我刚开始接触凯和泰勒时，在我看来，她们似乎很容易被那些极度渴望影响她们的人所左右。凯在尝试不同的决定，向男友寻求建议。泰勒则在向连名字都不知道的人寻求指导。
But then I started thinking, they actually were actively deciding what voices they wanted to let in, who exactly they wanted to be influenced by. In the middle of one of the most polarized debates in America, Kae and Taylor were trying to suss out what was right for them.
但后来我开始思考，她们实际上是在主动决定自己想听取哪些声音，想被谁影响。在这一场美国最极化的辩论中，凯和泰勒都在试图弄清楚什么对她们自己来说是正确的。
So I would read those comments all day. I would read those comments at night. I would read them at work. I would read them when I left work. And some of them didn't mean anything, but most of them actually meant a lot to me. But just being able to speak to someone freely and not feel like they're pushing you to a certain place-- I mean, they were pushing me, but they were also giving me what I asked for, which is a valid reason to not have an abortion.
所以我会整天整夜地阅读那些评论。我在上班时读，下班时也读。有些评论毫无意义，但大多数对我来说确实很重要。但能够自由地与人交谈，而不觉得他们强迫你做某种决定——当然，他们是在强迫我，但他们也给了我所要求的东西，也就是一个不堕胎的正当理由。
Ultimately, Taylor did go to Florida. She got on a plane to another state for an abortion. Her boyfriend picked her up from the airport at 11:00 PM.
最终，泰勒去了佛罗里达。她坐飞机去另一个州堕胎。男友在晚上11点从机场接她。
And the next morning, it was probably 6:00 AM, but my appointment was at 8:00. And he was just sleeping away, no problem, no whatever. But I was up. So I woke him up a little bit, and we talked.
第二天早上，大概是6点，但我预约的时间是8点。他睡得很熟，什么事都没有。但我醒了。所以我把他叫醒，我们谈了谈。
And they kept talking, about their parents, how they were raised, what they would want to do the same if they became parents, and what they would want to do differently. Her boyfriend said he worried his kid would struggle in school the same way he had. They wondered how much of that was genetic. They kept talking and talking.
他们不停地聊天，聊他们的父母，他们是如何长大的，如果他们成为父母，会想做哪些同样的事，又想做哪些不同的事。男友说他担心他的孩子会像他小时候那样在学校挣扎。他们想知道这有多少是遗传。他们不停地谈啊谈。
Yeah. I kept looking at the clock because it's like, all right, it's 6:30. Unless we throw our clothes on right now, we're going to be right on time. All right, it's 7:00. So when it started to get 7:10, 7:15, 7:30, it just kind of worked out in that way, where we just blew through the time and just ignored it.
是的。我不停地看表，因为想，好了，现在是6点半。除非我们现在穿上衣服冲过去，否则只能准时赶到。好了，7点了。当时间变成7点10分、7点15分、7点半时，事情自然而然地发展成这样：我们完全忽略了时间，把预约抛在了脑后。
Taylor never went to the appointment. Kae's pills arrived when she was eight weeks along. When Kae took them, she was in pain, more than she'd been expecting, which was scary because with all the new laws, Kate didn't feel safe calling a doctor. She didn't want to get in trouble.
泰勒最终没去那个预约。凯的药物在她怀孕八周时寄到了。当凯吃药时，她感到了比预期更剧烈的疼痛，这很吓人，因为随着所有新法律的出台，凯觉得打给医生不安全。她不想惹上麻烦。
I was in a lot of pain. I was cramping. I was bleeding. I went into this little bathroom. And I remember being so hot. Because I had the light on in the bathroom, the door was closed, so this heat was just building up from the light. And the only thing that I could think of to help the pain was a warm shower, even though like I was so hot.
我疼得厉害。我痉挛，出血。我走进那个小浴室。我记得非常热。因为浴室开着灯，门又关着，热量一直积聚。除了洗个热水澡，我想不出任何能缓解疼痛的方法，尽管当时我整个人都要热死了。
And I turned the shower on, and I contemplated getting in for a few minutes. Because I was like, oh my god, what if it doesn't help and I'm just roasting myself alive? And I ended up just getting in, and it was immense relief.
我打开淋浴，犹豫了几分钟要不要进去。因为我想，天哪，如果没用怎么办，我是不是在把自己烤熟？最终我还是进去了，那带来了极大的缓解。
It was done for Kae but not for Taylor.
这对凯来说结束了，但对泰勒来说却没有。
Caroline Kitchener, as we were putting this story together, the legal landscape changed a few times in many states, including Ohio, where Kae lives. Ohio's abortion ban was challenged in court. And right now, there's a temporary injunction, which means that abortion is still legal there for up to 22 weeks.
卡罗琳·基奇纳，在我们制作这个故事的过程中，许多州的法律环境发生了几次变化，包括凯居住的俄亥俄州。俄亥俄州的堕胎禁令在法庭上受到了挑战。目前，法院发布了一项临时禁令，这意味着在堕胎在22周内是合法的。
But abortion pills, like the ones that Kae took, may soon be harder to come by thanks to a decision just this week by a federal judge in Texas. That decision, if it stands, can make abortion pills harder to get in other states too. Coming up, what happens next with Taylor and how a video arcade can make almost anything feel better. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
但像凯服用的那种堕胎药，由于德克萨斯州一名联邦法官本周的裁决，可能很快就会更难获得。如果该裁决成立，它可能会使堕胎药在其他州也更难获取。接下来，泰勒会发生什么，以及电子游戏厅如何让一切感觉好转。在接下来的节目中，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目将继续。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, Nine Months Later, it's been nine months since the Supreme Court overturned Roe v. Wade. Our program today is about people who discovered that they were pregnant and did not want to be.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是：九个月后。距离最高法院推翻“罗诉韦德案”已经九个月了。我们今天的节目是关于那些发现自己怀孕却不想要孩子的人。
Right when that ruling came down and made abortions largely illegal in their states, we're following what's happened to those people in the first trimester, and now, in this next part of our show, in the second trimester.
就在那项裁决下达、使得堕胎在她们所在的州几乎变得非法的时候，我们跟踪报道了这些人在孕前三个月的经历，现在，在节目的下一部分，我们将进入孕中期。
Back before Roe fell, the vast number of abortions did happen in the first trimester. But now, because it can take so long to figure out what to do or for abortion pills to come in the mail, doctors say they're seeing an increasing number of people seeking abortions in the second trimester. There's a hotline, the Miscarriage and Abortion Hotline, which was started to help patients who are taking abortion pills at home. And it's been getting a lot more calls from people who are taking pills later in their pregnancy than the 10 weeks the FDA has approved.
在“罗案”倒台前，绝大多数堕胎发生在孕早期。但现在，因为搞清楚该怎么办或者等待邮寄的堕胎药需要很长时间，医生们表示，他们看到越来越多的寻求孕中期堕胎的人。有一个热线，即“流产与堕胎热线”，是为了帮助在家服用堕胎药的病人而设立的。它接到了越来越多电话，来自那些在孕期晚于FDA批准的10周期限后服用药物的人。
Now, to be clear, the pills are still safe after 10 weeks, but there can be complications. And the whole experience can be more intense.
现在，澄清一下，这些药物在10周后仍然是安全的，但可能会出现并发症。整个经历可能会更加剧烈。
People call a lot to just say, does this sound like it's going OK? Because I'm so afraid that if I need to get medical care, I'll get arrested.
人们打电话来通常只是想确认一下：听起来这种情况正常吗？因为我很害怕，如果我需要医疗护理，我会不会被捕。
Dr. Linda Prine, who helped start the hotline, talked with us and with a medical storytelling podcast called The Nocturnists about what she's been seeing. She says she used to answer questions from people in first trimester abortions about how much bleeding is normal, how do they know if the pills worked. But now she says at least once a day, she'll get a call that's very different.
琳达·普莱恩医生（Dr. Linda Prine），热线的共同发起人之一，与我们以及一个名为《夜班医生》（The Nocturnists）的医学故事播客分享了她的见闻。她说她过去常回答孕早期堕胎者的问题，比如多少出血量是正常的，如何知道药是否起效。但现在她说，每天至少会接到一个非常不同的电话。
It's taken them so long to get their pills that by the time they use them, they're 14 weeks, 16 weeks, 20 weeks. And we get calls about-- the fetus just came out, and I don't know what to do about the tissue that's stuck. How do I do this? There's the cord.
她们拿到药花的时间太长了，以至于服药时已经14周、16周甚至20周了。我们接到的电话是关于——胎儿刚出来，我不知道该怎么处理卡住的组织。我该怎么做？还有脐带。
Or I think the placenta stuck in my cervix. Or sometimes they don't have the vocabulary to explain what's happening. But they're just like, I can tell there's more tissue, and I don't know how to get it out. And what should I do?
或者我想胎盘卡在我的宫颈里了。有时她们甚至没有词汇来解释正在发生什么。但她们只是说，我能感觉到还有更多的组织，不知道怎么弄出来。我该怎么办？
At that point, she has to walk them through a second-trimester abortion over the phone. This is part of what the second trimester looks like now, more complicated, more frightening. And the people we talked to felt very alone. We spoke with nearly a dozen people who were looking for abortions in the weeks after Roe fell. And so many of them could not decide who to trust, who to ask for help. And there's one other thing that people talked about when they talked about what they were afraid of.
在那一刻，她必须通过电话引导她们进行孕中期堕胎。这就是现在孕中期的一部分面貌：更复杂，更令人恐惧。而我们采访的人感到非常孤独。我们采访了近十二个在“罗案”倒台后几周内寻求堕胎的人。她们中很多人不知道该信任谁，该向谁求助。当人们谈论她们害怕什么时，还有另外一件事。
I don't know how I would tell my mom.
我不知道怎么告诉我妈妈。
Katie had to travel out of state for her abortion. The only appointment she could get was the same weekend as her college orientation.
凯蒂不得不跨州堕胎。她能预约到的唯一时间刚好和大学迎新周重叠。
And there was no way of rescheduling it because I wouldn't know how to tell my mom of why I wanted to reschedule it.
而且没有办法重新安排，因为我不知道怎么告诉我妈我为什么要改期。
Moms, there's no figure we heard about more than moms. People did not want to have to talk to their moms about their abortions. It was hard. Their mom called all the time or asked how they were. But they needed their mom to drive them across state lines, like Brianna, who says she heard over 12 hours in the car of--
妈妈，我们听到的关于妈妈的谈论比任何人都多。人们不想告诉妈妈自己堕胎的事。这太难了。她们的妈妈经常打电话来或问她们怎么样。但她们又需要妈妈开车送她们跨越州界，比如布里安娜，她说她在车上听了12个小时的——
It was like, I don't think you should do this, but it's your life. And so I was like, you're not helping.
就像是，我不觉得你应该这么做，但这毕竟是你的人生。所以我说，你根本没在帮我。
I wish I didn't have to say anything to my mom at all, but I needed the childcare. We needed the help for the weekend.
我真希望不必对妈妈说任何话，但我需要有人看孩子。我们需要周末的帮助。
Ashley had to figure out what to say about why she needed to leave town.
阿什莉得想好该说些什么来解释为什么要离开城镇。
We just lied. She was extremely helpful that weekend as far as-- I think she took the kids one day so that my husband had to work Saturday. But I had to yeah, lie.
我们只是撒了谎。那个周末她帮了大忙，就……我想有一天她带了孩子，这样我丈夫周六就得工作。但我不得不，是的，撒谎。
I could not tell my mom.
我没法告诉我妈。
This is Jessica in Texas.
这是德克萨斯州的杰西卡。
Telling her that I was pregnant and was not sure if I was going to keep it would have probably devastated her.
告诉她我怀孕了，还不确定是否要留下孩子，这可能会让她崩溃。
There was one post Roe second-trimester pregnancy that especially drew Caroline in, Caroline Kitchener, the reporter from the Washington Post that we're doing today's show with. This particular pregnancy was in Oklahoma, a teenage girl named Lilly, who couldn't get an abortion without pulling in her parents-- in this case, her dad. Again, here's Caroline.
有一个“罗案”后孕中期的案例特别吸引卡罗琳·基奇纳的注意，就是那位来自《华盛顿邮报》、与我们合作今天节目的记者。这个特定的案例发生在俄克拉荷马州，是一名17岁的女孩，名叫莉莉。她无法在不告知父母的情况下堕胎——在这种情况下是她的父亲。再次有请卡罗琳。
I met Lilly a few days after she got her positive pregnancy test. She was 17 years old and well into her second trimester. I liked Lilly right away. She was silly, made me feel old, but in a super endearing kind of way. Lilly told me she'd known this boy for a while and they had an on-again, off-again thing since sophomore year.
在莉莉得知自己怀孕测试呈阳性后的几天，我见到了她。她17岁，已经进入了孕中期。我立刻就喜欢上了莉莉。她很顽皮，让我感到自己老了，但以一种超级讨人喜欢的方式。莉莉告诉我，她认识这个男孩有一阵子了，从高二开始他们就断断续续地在一起。
I don't know how to explain it. He's very funny, and he's very sweet and very caring. He's a little stupid, but that's OK. And yeah, we had just started hanging out again, I think. Because we had been going to lunch and stuff because at my school, we had gotten 15-minute lunches.
我不知道怎么解释。他很有趣，非常贴心，非常细心。他有点笨，但没关系。是的，我想我们刚开始又在一起了。因为我们经常去吃午饭，在学校里，我们有15分钟的午餐时间。
And then he was like, hey, what you doing? And I was like, oh, dear god . And then it all kind of just restarted.
然后他问，嘿，你在干嘛？我说，噢，天哪。然后一切就重新开始了。
Lilly had no idea she was pregnant through the entire first trimester. She had just graduated from high school, still riding high off prom. She was making her own money working at a sandwich shop, staying out late with friends. Somewhere down the line, she thought she might go to culinary school. Or she had an idea for a business that combined her two favorite things, tattoos and food. She would call it Pies and Pokes.
莉莉在整个孕早期完全不知道自己怀孕了。她刚高中毕业，还沉浸在舞会的余韵中。她靠在三明治店打工赚钱，和朋友们玩到很晚。她曾想过有一天去厨艺学校。或者她有一个商业点子，结合了她最喜欢的两件事：纹身和食物。她打算叫它“馅饼与刺青”（Pies and Pokes）。
Lilly's the youngest of five. The older siblings have all moved out already, so it's just her and her dad in the house together.
莉莉是五个孩子中最小的。年长的兄弟姐妹都搬出去了，所以家里只有她和父亲住在一起。
You know what you picture when you picture a single, divorced dad? [LAUGHS] Like, he doesn't know how to decorate. We shop nightly for meals. He won't go shopping for a lot of things to keep the fridge or the pantry stocked. We'll just go as we need, or we'll go buy food at fast-food places or go to restaurants. And I just think it's hilarious.
你知道单身离异父亲的刻板印象吗？[笑] 比如，他根本不知道怎么装修房子。我们每天晚上都得去买吃的。他不愿意买太多东西来填充冰箱或储藏室。我们随吃随买，或者去快餐店或餐馆吃。我觉得这太搞笑了。
Here's how Lilly found out she was pregnant. She was at work, and she called her dad with really bad stomach cramps. They ended up in the ER, where they took Lily's vitals and took some urine. And the doctor came in the room with this weird look on his face. He asked Lilly if she was OK talking with her dad in the room. Lilly was like, yeah, of course, talk about what? He told her, you're pregnant.
这就是莉莉发现自己怀孕的过程。她在上班时感到胃部剧痛，给父亲打了电话。他们最终去了急诊室，医生记录了莉莉的生命体征并验了尿。医生走进房间时脸色很奇怪。他问莉莉在父亲面前谈话是否没问题。莉莉说，当然，谈什么？他告诉她，你怀孕了。
And I looked at my dad. And I remember him getting all shocked and looking at me. It was-- good lord. He looked like he was definitely panicking but trying not to show me because he knew I was panicking. Because I was visibly panicking.
我看向爸爸。我记得他表现得非常震惊，看向我。那真是……天哪。他看起来绝对是慌了神，但试图不让我看出来，因为他知道我也在慌。因为我当时明显在惊慌。
How were you-- what do you think you were doing--
你是怎么——你觉得你在做什么——
Oh, I was crying. I was crying immediately. I literally, instantly started just sobbing.
噢，我在哭。我立刻就开始哭。我真的瞬间就开始抽泣。
It turned out she was about 19 weeks along. The doctor handed her the test results and told her that she could put them in her baby book. He kept talking, but Lilly was just staring at her dad, studying his face.
原来她已经怀孕19周了。医生把检查结果递给她，告诉她可以把结果放进她的婴儿纪念册里。他还在说，但莉莉只是盯着父亲，审视着他的脸。
I just remember being scared. I felt shaky. And I kind of wanted to know if he was mad at me or really just what he was thinking about, honestly.
我只记得当时很害怕。我觉得发抖。老实说，我其实很想知道他是在生我的气，还是在想些什么。
He said nothing. But at one point, he did reach out to hold her hand. They left the room, walked to the car in silence. As they were driving home, Lilly said he asked her right off the bat--
他什么也没说。但在某个时刻，他确实伸手握住了她的手。他们离开房间，默默地走向车子。在回家的路上，莉莉说他单刀直入地问她——
Do you know whose it is? And I was, like, yeah. And he was like, well, whose is it? And I was like, um-- because I didn't want to tell him because he knows the guy. And I was like, oh god.
你知道是谁的孩子吗？我说，嗯，知道。他说，那是谁的？我说，呃……因为我不想告诉他，因为他认识那个人。我心想，哦天哪。
And did you?
那你说了吗？
Yeah. Then he was like, oh my god. I should have your brothers kill him, da, da, da, da, da.
说了。然后他说，噢，我的天哪。我应该让你的哥哥们去把他杀掉，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒。
She rolled her eyes, and then the conversation was very much over. They drove home. She went to her bedroom. He went to his.
她翻了个白眼，然后对话就结束了。他们开车回家。她回了房间。他也回了房间。
The next day, Lilly sat in her room while her dad went to work. And it really started to hit her. She was pregnant, and abortion was now illegal in Oklahoma. There was no doubt in Lilly's mind, she wanted an abortion.
第二天，莉莉坐在房间里，父亲去上班了。她才真正意识到发生了什么。她怀孕了，而俄克拉荷马州现在堕胎是非法的。莉莉心里毫无疑问，她想要堕胎。
Had she found out earlier in her pregnancy, before Oklahoma banned abortion, Lilly could have driven 30 minutes to a clinic to get one. But now she had to find a different way. First, she tried clinics in Kansas, but the clinic she called told her that she was too far along for them to see her. Then she tried New Mexico. They didn't have appointments for three to four weeks.
如果在孕期早些时候，在俄克拉荷马州禁止堕胎前发现，莉莉本来可以开车30分钟去诊所堕胎。但现在她必须找到别的方法。起初，她试着联系堪萨斯的诊所，但对方告诉她孕周太大，无法接诊。然后她尝试了新墨西哥州。他们三到四周内都没有预约空位。
I talked to Lilly a whole bunch right around this time. She was terrified. One clinic told her she was so far along, they would have to induce labor to end the pregnancy. Lilly told me she couldn't imagine pushing a baby out of her 95-pound body.
这段时间我频繁和莉莉交流。她吓坏了。一家诊所告诉她，由于孕周太长，他们必须引产才能结束妊娠。莉莉告诉我，她无法想象要从她那95磅重的身体里把一个婴儿生出来。
Do you think you sounded scared on those calls?
你觉得你在那些电话里听起来很害怕吗？
Probably, yeah. I was very nervous, and it was not fun to say on the phone repeatedly.
大概是吧。我很紧张，反复在电话里说那些话一点都不好受。
She kept calling and calling. Eventually, she found one clinic in New Mexico with an appointment the following week. She knew she wouldn't be able to get there on her own. She knew she was going to need her dad.
她不停地打电话。最终，她在新墨西哥州找到了一家诊所，预约到了下周。她知道自己没法独自前往。她知道她需要父亲。
Lilly's dad is former Air Force. Now he works in IT. He loves music Lilly likes to describe as dad rock-- AC/DC, Bon Jovi. He has five kids, three boys and two girls. He grew up in a conservative family, believing it was wrong to have an abortion. Lilly didn't know what he would think about her wanting an abortion.
莉莉的父亲贾斯汀（Justin）是空军退役人员。现在从事IT工作。他喜欢那种莉莉称之为“老爸摇滚”的音乐——AC/DC、邦·乔维（Bon Jovi）。他有五个孩子，三个男孩，两个女孩。他在一个保守的家庭长大，认为堕胎是错误的。莉莉不知道他会怎么看她想要堕胎的想法。
I was just nervous to tell him, honestly. I was nervous to see his reaction.
老实说，我只是紧张得不敢告诉他。我紧张得想看他的反应。
What were you worried about?
你担心什么？
I just didn't want him to be disappointed, I guess.
我想，我只是不想让他感到失望。
A few days later, her dad finally asked her, so what are you going to do? She told him, I'm not going to have a kid. He said, you know how hard that's going to be now, right? Lilly knew.
几天后，父亲终于问她：那么，你打算怎么做？她说：我不打算要孩子。他说：你知道现在这有多难了吗？莉莉知道。
Then her dad walked out. He said he needed a little time to process that information. Lilly decided, in her head, that what her dad was not saying was that he wanted her to keep the baby.
然后父亲走了出去。他说他需要一点时间来消化这个信息。莉莉在心里认定，父亲没说出口的意思就是他想让她留下孩子。
It was kind of hard. Because I can handle my dad being mad at me. Him being disappointed in me is a whole different story.
这有点难。因为我可以应对爸爸生我的气。但他对我感到失望，那是完全另一回事。
Was he actually disappointed? Did he actually not want her to get the abortion? What was he thinking when the doctor told them she was pregnant? When they drove home that night, Lilly hadn't asked him. So I did.
他真的失望吗？他真的不想让她堕胎吗？当医生告诉他们她怀孕时，他在想什么？那天晚上开车回家时，莉莉没问。所以我问了。
The first thing was, who is this kid? Because there's a butt kicking coming.
第一反应是，这混蛋是谁？因为得有人揍他一顿。
You mean, who is this person who impregnated her?
你的意思是，那个让她怀孕的人是谁？
Yeah, yeah. And when she told me, it kind of infuriated me a little bit more.
对，对。当她告诉我那是谁时，我感到更加愤怒了。
Why?
为什么？
Well, because-- so the guy, he'd already gotten another 15, 16-year-old girl pregnant and had a baby with her. So yeah. The next thing in my mind is I'm calling the three brothers, and this is getting handled. That was the immediate, you've ruined your life. You're 17 years old. You're going to have a baby now.
嗯，因为——那个男孩，他已经让另一个15、16岁的女孩怀孕并有了孩子。所以，是的。我脑子里的下一个想法是，我要打电话给那三个哥哥，这件事得处理掉。那种即刻的反应是：你毁了你自己。你才17岁。你现在要有个孩子了。
A, how are you going to take care of this baby? You don't even have a job. No, I think she was working at that point. You're working at Jersey Mike's, making minimum wage. I have just gotten out of finally paying off your medical bills for your broken leg, which was also the result of a horrible decision on your part. What were you thinking?
第一，你打算怎么照顾这个孩子？你甚至没有工作。不，我想那时候她在打工。你在Jersey Mike's三明治店打工，挣最低工资。我才刚付清你摔断腿的医疗费，那也是因为你做出了可怕的决定。你当时在想什么？
When Lilly told her dad, Justin, that she wanted an abortion, she imagined he was angry or upset. But he told me he wasn't. He was really just surprised.
当莉莉告诉父亲贾斯汀她想要堕胎时，她以为他会生气或难过。但他告诉我，他没有。他只是真的很惊讶。
I didn't think, knowing Grace, that it was going to be an option for her.
考虑到我对格蕾丝（Grace）的了解，我没想到这会是她的一个选项。
Grace is his nickname for Lilly. He's always called her that.
格蕾丝是他的昵称，莉莉的小名。他一直这么叫她。
I don't know why. That was my first instinct, was she's going to have his baby. I don't know why--
我不知道为什么。我的第一直觉是，她会生下那个孩子的。我不知道为什么——
Why, why?
为什么，为什么？
--I thought that.
——我会有那种想法。
Because when she talks about it, it's like there was no room for that. So it's interesting that, knowing her as well as you do, that's where your mind went.
因为当她谈起这件事时，听起来根本没有留出那种空间。所以很有趣，因为像你这样了解她，你却往那个方向想。
This may sound terrible, but it probably was a result of how nurturing she is. She doesn't even like to step on spiders, you know what I'm saying? So I just never thought that that would be an option for her.
这听起来可能很糟糕，但这大概是因为她太有爱心了。她甚至连踩死一只蜘蛛都不忍心，你知道我的意思吗？所以我从没想到过这对她来说会是一个选择。
But Justin quickly moved past shock and into action mode. He assumed that this was something that he needed to make happen for his daughter. The day Lilly told him she wanted an abortion, Justin went to work and researched. He looked up clinics. He had no idea that Lilly, his baby-- now his anxious and somewhat irresponsible teenager-- she was way ahead of him.
但贾斯汀很快从震惊转向了行动模式。他认为这是他需要为女儿去做的事情。在莉莉告诉他她想要堕胎的那天，贾斯汀去工作并进行了研究。他查了诊所。他根本没想到莉莉——他的小宝贝，那个焦虑又有点不负责任的十几岁女孩，已经走在他前面了。
Didn't really hear from her much that day. And I get home, fully, she's laying on her bed. She's got her little notebook out. And she's got some kind of gangster rap going on the freaking-- on the Alexa. And she's called 14 different places. She's called the Roe v. Wade fund. She's called everything, and she's basically got a plan in place. And I'm like, oh, wow.
那天没怎么听到她的动静。我回家时，她完全是躺在床上。她拿着她的小笔记本。她在Alexa上放着某种匪帮说唱音乐。她打了14个不同的地方。她打给了罗诉韦德基金，打给了所有地方，她基本上已经有了计划。我当时想，噢，哇。
So you thought you were going to be the one making the phone calls.
所以你还以为你会是那个打电话的人。
I did. I absolutely did. It amazed me because that is not a trait she had displayed before. And her calmness during it, that's what really stood out. She didn't panic. She wasn't like, oh, Dad, help me. She was like, OK, well, I got to call this guy. I got to call this guy.
我是这么想的。绝对是的。这让我感到惊奇，因为这是她以前从没表现出来的特质。她在过程中的冷静，那才是真正让我印象深刻的。她没有恐慌。她没有说，噢，爸爸，帮帮我。她只是说，好吧，我要打电话给这个人。我要打电话给那个人。
What did you want her to do? What decision did you want her to make?
你想要她怎么做？你希望她做出什么决定？
That's a great question. Hm. I think if you had to say what was your top choice, I would have said, yeah, I wanted her to keep the baby.
这是一个很好的问题。嗯。我想如果你问我首选是什么，我会说，是的，我想让她留下孩子。
Why do you think your top choice was for her to keep it?
你为什么觉得你的首选是让她留下孩子？
That probably is very psychologically deep. And it probably has to do with Grace getting to the point where she's going to leave and feeling all my children are out. Kinsie has her own kid. Michael is out there in the world, doing his thing. Christopher and Brady are out in the world.
这可能涉及非常深层的心理问题。这可能与格蕾丝即将离开，让我感到我的所有孩子都要离巢有关。金西（Kinsie）有她自己的孩子。迈克尔（Michael）在外面的世界闯荡。克里斯托弗（Christopher）和布雷迪（Brady）也都在外。
So Grace is all I have left that I know needs me. Her daily survival, to some degree, depends on me. And I've gone almost longer in my life with that than without that. So I don't know how to be the me before the kids. For the last 27 years, I always had somebody that needed me.
所以格蕾丝是我仅存的我知道需要我的人。她的日常生存，在某种程度上取决于我。我生命中绝大多数时间都是在有这种依赖的状态中度过的。所以我不知道没有孩子之前的那个自己是什么样子。在过去的27年里，总有人需要我。
So I know if Grace has this baby, I got another at least 18 to 20 years of being needed. And that may be purely selfish, but I hope that my concern for her outweighed my selfishness in that situation.
所以我知道，如果格蕾丝有了这个孩子，我至少还有18到20年是被需要的。这可能非常自私，但我希望在这种情况下，我对她的关心胜过了我的自私。
Justin wasn't sure he could trust his own impulses or his own feelings. That's why he didn't talk to Lilly. To her, it seemed like disapproval. But Justin was really just trying to give her space, not share too much of his own complicated thoughts. He knew Lilly would have a hard time ignoring anything he said.
贾斯汀不确定自己能否信任自己的冲动或感受。这就是为什么他没有和莉莉交谈。对她来说，这看起来像是不同意。但贾斯汀真的只是想给她空间，不分享太多自己复杂的想法。他知道莉莉很难忽视他说的任何话。
When Lilly asked him to drive her to New Mexico for the abortion, Justin said yes. She'd gotten the funds. She'd made the appointment. She had a plan.
当莉莉请求他开车带她去新墨西哥州堕胎时，贾斯汀答应了。她筹到了钱。她完成了预约。她有计划。
Lilly was 20 weeks pregnant when she and her dad loaded up the car to drive to New Mexico together. They stocked up on her favorite road trip snacks, Pringles and pudding cups. It was their first road trip together, just the two of them. And Justin told me, with everything Lilly had been through, he wanted to make sure they did something fun along the way, which was funny because Lilly told me this about heading out on that trip with her dad.
莉莉怀孕20周时，她和父亲装上车，一起开车前往新墨西哥州。他们储备了她最喜欢的公路旅行零食：品客薯片和布丁杯。这是他们第一次只有两个人的公路旅行。贾斯汀告诉我，考虑到莉莉经历的一切，他想确保他们在路上做些有趣的事情，这很滑稽，因为莉莉告诉我关于这次和父亲出行的想法是——
I wanted him to have at least some sort of fun while he was out here. I thought it was really sweet that he was trying to make me feel better. And obviously, it's not fun for me, but I know it's not fun to have to see your kid-- I wanted him to have some good memory.
我想让他在外面的时候至少能享受一点乐趣。我觉得他试图让我感觉好点真是太贴心了。显然，对我来说这并不愉快，但我知道要看着自己的孩子经历这种事也不愉快——我想让他留下一些美好的回忆。
When it was time for the procedure, it took two days. Because she was so far along, the doctor had to insert dilation sticks to soften and open her cervix. Then Lilly and her dad went to the hotel. Then they went back to the clinic in the morning, and the doctor used suction to empty the uterus for about 20 minutes until the fetus was entirely out.
手术过程持续了两天。因为孕周太大，医生必须插入扩宫棒来软化并打开宫颈。然后莉莉和父亲去了酒店。第二天早上，他们回到诊所，医生使用抽吸法清理子宫，持续了约20分钟，直到胎儿完全取出。
Lilly said the nurse woke her up and told her, you're done. You are no longer pregnant. She immediately noticed that her stomach didn't feel full anymore. She said it felt flat again.
莉莉说护士把她叫醒，告诉她：好了。你已经不再怀孕了。她立刻感觉到肚子不再是满的了。她说感觉又变平了。
Afterward, Lilly told Justin she wanted to go to the arcade in the mall. She wanted to try the DDR machine. But mostly, she wanted to go because she thought her dad would love it.
事后，莉莉告诉贾斯汀她想去商场里的游乐厅。她想尝试跳舞机（DDR）。但主要是，她想去是因为她觉得爸爸一定会喜欢。
But I was incredibly nauseous and in a bunch of pain but we still went because ball out.
但我当时恶心极了，还疼得厉害，但我们还是去了，因为要玩个痛快。
So she was she was sick in the car in the parking lot when we pulled up in the mall, but she was determined that she wanted to go to the arcade. So I'm like, all right, well, we'll go.
所以当我们要进商场停车场时，她就在车里病了，但她坚持说想去游乐厅。我说，好吧，那我们去吧。
Was there any part of you that was like, really? Like, why do you want to do this when you're like actively sick and throwing up?
有没有哪一刻你觉得，真的吗？当你实际上病得在呕吐时，为什么要这样做？
I was kind of proud. I'm like, all right, yeah, a little vomit ain't going to stop us from playing some games. And after she threw up, she felt better.
我有点自豪。我心想，好吧，一点点呕吐阻止不了我们玩游戏。她吐完之后，感觉好多了。
So we're walking around. And for a while, it was fun. And we're playing games. We're winning toys and such. And I think we ordered a pretzel or something, maybe, from the little snack bar or whatever.
所以我们在四处走。有一阵子挺开心的。我们在玩游戏。我们赢了玩具之类的。我想我们在小食吧点了个椒盐脆饼还是什么。
And we played a bunch of claw games, and my dad won me a little duck in a hoodie. It's really cute. I still have it. I named him Mr. Quacker.
我们玩了一堆娃娃机，我爸给我赢了一只穿着连帽衫的小鸭子。真的很可爱。我留着它。我给它取名“嘎嘎先生”（Mr. Quacker）。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
But then Lilly started feeling sick again.
但随后莉莉开始感到不舒服了。
And so we're walking around, trying to find the bathroom. And she's like, I am not going to make it. And I'm like, well, then just go hide behind one of the arcade machines. And she, sure enough, made it to the side of one of the arcade machines and then she just launched it. And I'm like, yeah, we should probably go ahead and head home now.
我们四处走动，试图找到厕所。她说，我坚持不住了。我说，那你就躲到其中一台游乐机后面去。结果她真的撑到了其中一台游戏机旁，然后就吐了。我说，好吧，我们现在应该回家了。
I was walking away to go find a worker to tell someone, hey, I just threw up on your ground. I'm so sorry. My dad, my grown-man dad, he goes, no, it's fine. They deal with this all the time. Let's just leave. And we just left.
我正走开去找个员工告诉对方，嘿，我刚才在你的地上吐了。我太抱歉了。我的爸爸，一个成年男人，他说，不，没关系。他们每天处理这种事。我们走吧。然后我们就离开了。
She's like, do I need to tell somebody? And I'm like, I'm sure they're going to figure it out. [LAUGHS]
她说，我需要告诉谁吗？我说，我相信他们会弄明白的。[笑]
It was an eight-hour drive back to Oklahoma. They left at 5:00 AM the next morning. Justin drove. Lilly slept in the passenger seat. By afternoon, they were home, back to regular life, back to their routines, still just the two of them.
回俄克拉荷马州有八小时的车程。第二天早上5点他们就出发了。贾斯汀开车。莉莉在副驾驶座睡觉。下午的时候他们到了家，回到了正常生活，回到了各自的节奏中，依旧只是他们父女俩。
Third trimester. Now that we're nine months out from the Supreme Court decision, this first group of people who wanted abortions, but they live in states with abortion bans, have had time to think about where they landed, how these laws affected them. People had very different takeaways.
孕晚期。现在距离最高法院的裁决已经九个月了，第一批想堕胎但生活在堕胎禁令州的人，有时间去思考她们的处境，以及这些法律是如何影响她们的。人们的感受大相径庭。
One woman in Mississippi told us she thinks her abortion saved her life and the laws just stood in her way. She had a medical condition that made her pregnancy life-threatening. A woman in Texas said the experience made her swear off men. Another woman in Texas said it made her swear off Texas. The anti-abortion forces and laws in the state seem so menacing, she didn't even want to reveal that she was pregnant on the standard medical form that you fill out at the chiropractor's office.
密西西比州的一位妇女告诉我们，她认为她的堕胎拯救了她的生命，而这些法律只是挡在了她的路上。她有一种使怀孕危及生命的健康状况。德克萨斯州的一名妇女说，这次经历让她发誓不再和男人交往。另一位德克萨斯州的妇女说，这让她发誓永远离开德克萨斯。该州的反堕胎力量和法律看起来如此可怕，她甚至不想在脊椎按摩师诊所填写的标准医疗表格上透露自己怀孕了。
I didn't want to let anybody know I was pregnant. And I was afraid that I was going to be reported. I don't know how they handle it. People were afraid of period apps, for god's sakes, putting down that they were missing periods.
我不想让任何人知道我怀孕了。我担心我会因此被举报。我不知道他们怎么处理这件事。天哪，人们甚至害怕使用月经追踪软件，害怕记录她们月经推迟。
She left Texas for months.
她离开德克萨斯好几个月。
But a college freshman named Katie told us that the biggest aftereffect of her abortion and the new laws was that it led to a lot of awkward conversations with family and friends because she didn't want to tell everybody about her abortion. She wanted to be one of the millions of people who have had abortions and were able to put it away, move on, not think about it again.
但一位名叫凯蒂的大一新生告诉我们，堕胎和新法律对她最大的后遗症是导致她与家人和朋友之间产生了许多尴尬的对话，因为她不想告诉所有人她堕胎的事。她想成为数百万堕胎后能够放下、继续前行、不再去想它的人之一。
This was not the year for that. Abortion was constantly in the news. People were talking about it all the time. And Katie's roommate talked about how annoying the anti-abortion protesters were in the quad. Katie wanted to agree but without disclosing too much about her own abortion.
今年情况并非如此。堕胎一直出现在新闻中。人们一直都在谈论它。凯蒂的室友谈到反堕胎抗议者在校园广场上有多烦人。凯蒂想表示赞同，却不能透露太多关于她自己堕胎的细节。
And I told her that I had a friend that had to go to Louisiana and Washington and all this stuff because of Roe v. Wade got overturned. And if Texas didn't have all these laws, it would have been so much easier on her. But she had to wait so long just because of Roe v. Wade.
我告诉她，我有个朋友因为“罗案”被推翻而不得不去路易斯安那州和华盛顿州等地。如果德克萨斯州没有这些法律，她本来会轻松得多。但她因为“罗案”不得不等了那么久。
For Ashley, the new laws dominated a lot of her last year. She was in the unusual situation that under the abortion ban, she left the state to get an abortion, and then, months later, she discovered she was pregnant again. Everything about how she felt about this new pregnancy was shaped by that first post Roe abortion. She'd had her mom watch her three kids when she went out of state but lied to her about where she was going and what she was doing, and she'd turned to an abortion fund to help pay for it last time around. Now, pregnant again and thinking about a second abortion--
对于阿什莉来说，新法律影响了她过去一年的生活。她的情况很特殊：在堕胎禁令下，她离州去做了堕胎，几个月后，她发现自己又怀孕了。她对这次新怀孕的所有感受都被第一次“罗案”后的堕胎经历所塑造。她曾让妈妈照顾三个孩子自己离州，但对妈妈撒谎说自己去了哪里、做了什么；上次她还求助于堕胎基金来支付费用。现在，又怀孕了，考虑第二次堕胎——
I felt selfish. I felt like I was taking the fund resources away from the 17-year-old who needed it way more than me. I just felt horribly selfish, and I didn't feel like it was a situation that I could put myself and my whole family through again. I can't travel another 1,800 miles and lie to my family and my kids about where Mommy is when I have a spot in my van. And we have a happy home. And we have space and love. So basically, I didn't feel like I could do it again and still feel good about it.
我觉得很自私。我觉得自己是在从那个比我更需要资源的人手里抢钱，比如那个17岁的女孩。我只是觉得自己无比自私，而且我觉得这对我自己和整个家庭来说，并不是我能再次经历的情况。我不能再跨越1800英里，对我的家人和孩子撒谎说妈妈在哪里，而我的面包车里还有空间。我们有一个幸福的家。我们有空间和爱。所以基本上，我觉得我没法再做一次，并且还能问心无愧。
So she was keeping the pregnancy, even though her reasons for the first abortion still stood. She still had three kids on Medicaid. Her husband still didn't make enough money. And she still did not want to be pregnant.
所以她决定留下孩子，尽管她第一次堕胎的理由依然存在。她依然有三个孩子靠医疗补助（Medicaid）生活。她丈夫赚的钱依然不够多。而且她依然不想怀孕。
Then it made me start to realize how many mothers of multiple children have to just pile another kid in there when they really didn't want to. Sometimes it's people that already have a minivan and have the space and have the love, which makes us feel even worse. But just because we have the space and we have the love doesn't mean we wanted to do that.
这件事让我开始意识到，有多少养育着多个孩子的母亲，在并不想要的情况下只能再增加一个孩子。有时这些人已经有了面包车，有空间，有爱，这让我们感觉更糟。但仅仅因为我们有空间、有爱，并不代表我们想要那样做。
Which brings us to the most consequential result of the new laws. The first group of post Roe babies, babies who never would have been born had the Supreme Court had not acted, are now coming into the world. One of those babies is Taylor's. You heard Taylor earlier, the Reddit nerd in Atlanta who flew to Florida for an abortion, but in the end, didn't go to her appointment. Caroline has been tracking what's happened since then, and that's where we'll end today's show.
这带出了新法律最深远的后果。第一批“罗案”后的婴儿——那些如果最高法院没有采取行动本不会出生的孩子——正在来到这个世界上。其中一个孩子是泰勒的。你之前听到了泰勒的故事，那个在亚特兰大、飞往佛罗里达堕胎，但最终没有去诊所的Reddit用户。卡罗琳一直在跟踪之后发生的事，这就是我们今天节目结束的地方。
By the time Taylor entered her third trimester, she was very alone. It happened week by week. When she was 13 weeks pregnant, coming home to Atlanta, Taylor's mom and sister wanted to celebrate. They asked, can we rub your belly? Can we throw you a baby shower? No and no. Taylor was not interested.
当泰勒进入孕晚期时，她非常孤独。事情是一周一周发生的。当她怀孕13周回到亚特兰大时，泰勒的妈妈和姐妹想庆祝。她们问：我们可以摸摸你的肚子吗？我们可以给你办产前派对吗？不行，不行。泰勒毫无兴趣。
I didn't want people to get me things I didn't want. I didn't want my family to feel responsible for something that I really didn't plan to do. If I was married or something, I'd have a baby shower. But this is not the same type of situation. So I didn't want to ask anyone for anything.
我不想要别人送我不想要的东西。我不想要家人对一件我真的没打算做的事感到责任。如果我结婚了之类的，我会办派对。但现在情况不同。所以我不想向任何人索取任何东西。
It was almost like she had decided this was her thing. She got pregnant without planning to, so she was going to deal with it all by herself. Taylor's family was offended, which made Taylor want to pull away even more. By the time she was around 16 weeks pregnant, Taylor and her mom were no longer speaking.
就像她决定了这是她自己的事。她意外怀孕，所以她打算独自处理这一切。泰勒的家人感到被冒犯，这让泰勒更想退缩。当她怀孕大约16周时，泰勒和妈妈不再说话了。
18 weeks, Taylor and her boyfriend were fighting. She wanted him to move back to Atlanta. He wanted her to move to Florida. They broke up.
18周，泰勒和男友吵架了。她想让他搬回亚特兰大。他想让她搬去佛罗里达。他们分手了。
At 22 weeks, Taylor was trying to take control of the situation. She would buy all the right baby things, line them up in all the right spots in her house, a mini fridge by the bed to store breast milk, small stacks of diapers in every room, so she could reach every little thing she needed when it was just her and the baby. This way, she thought, she could do this alone.
22周，泰勒试图掌控局面。她购买了所有合适的婴儿用品，把它们摆在家里合适的位置：床边放个迷你冰箱储存母乳，房间里堆着成叠的尿布，这样她就能在只有她和孩子时拿到所需的一切。她想，这样她就能独自应付了。
At 24 weeks, Taylor lost her job. She needed to pass a test to keep it. And with everything that was happening with the baby, she said she just couldn't focus. 25 weeks, Taylor asked her ex, what role do you want with this baby? He said, I want to be involved. But there's wanting to be involved and being able to. She took that to mean he's out.
24周，泰勒丢了工作。她得通过考试才能保住职位。但随着孩子的一切发生，她说她根本无法集中精神。25周，泰勒问前任：你想要在这个孩子生活中扮演什么角色？他说：我想参与。但“想参与”和“能够参与”是两回事。她认为他的意思是彻底退出。
So as she entered her third trimester, Taylor started imagining herself alone in the delivery room. She would Uber herself to the hospital. She scheduled a C-section. Four days before the date, I caught Taylor running around, getting ready. At that point, she said she didn't want anybody with her, especially her family.
所以当她进入孕晚期时，泰勒开始想象自己独自待在产房里。她会打Uber去医院。她安排了剖腹产。在日期前四天，我看到泰勒在到处忙碌。在那一刻，她说她不想让任何人陪她，尤其是家人。
Yeah, because I don't want everybody crowding me right after the birth, and then I don't want everybody in my house at the same time. And these are going to be my first moments learning how to be a mom. And I don't want to do that in front of anybody either.
是的，因为我不想在孩子出生后所有人都围着我，我也不想所有人都同时挤在我的房子里。这些将是我学习当妈妈的第一刻。我也不想在任何人面前做这些。
On March 24, Taylor gave birth to a baby boy, exactly, to the day, nine months after the Supreme Court overturned Roe v. Wade.
3月24日，泰勒生下了一个男婴，刚好是在最高法院推翻“罗诉韦德案”九个月整的那一天。
It went so freaking well.
一切进展得太顺利了。
I called her when she got home from the hospital.
她在出院后我打电话给她。
Let me tell you something. The weirdest part about it is how fast it was. It was like 10 minutes that they pulled this kid out of me. I felt pressure. And then the next thing you know, there's a [BLEEP] kid. It was crazy.
我告诉你一件事。最奇怪的部分是速度太快了。他们把孩子从我肚子里拉出来好像只用了10分钟。我感觉到了压力。然后下一秒，就多出了一个[哔]孩子。真是疯了。
I don't think there will ever be anything that will measure up to how surreal it felt to see a child come out of your stomach. It's just like, whoa, I created that. You're just in shock. Like, this is me? This is all me. I created this.
我想永远没有什么能比得上看到孩子从你肚子里出来那种超现实的感觉。就像是，哇，我创造了那个生命。你简直惊呆了。就像是，这是我？这一切都是我。我创造了这个。
And he came out with his eyes wide open. He was very aware. He's beautiful. He's quiet. He's not a normal baby. He's just a super baby. Black, dark black hair. He's really perfect. If you wanted a kid, he'd be like the blueprint.
他出来时眼睛睁得大大的。他非常清醒。他很漂亮。他很安静。他不是那种普通的孩子。他简直是个超级宝宝。皮肤黑黑的，头发黑黑的。他真的完美无缺。如果你想要个孩子，他就是蓝图。
In the end, Taylor wasn't alone in the hospital. She asked her cousin to give her a ride to the hospital. The cousin stayed and took a video of the birth. And Taylor says the cousin must have called other people in the family, because the day she gave birth--
最后，泰勒在医院里并不孤单。她请求表姐开车送她去医院。表姐留下来拍了分娩视频。泰勒说表姐一定打电话给家人了，因为生孩子的当天——
My father came, same day. He also showed up the next day. My mom came the next day, and she stayed the night every night after that. And then I also had family that just won't leave. They're like, I won't say or do anything. I just want to be here.
我父亲来了，同一天。他第二天也出现了。我妈妈第二天也来了，之后每天晚上都留下来。然后还有其他亲戚，怎么也不肯走。他们说：我不会说什么也不会做什么。我只是想待在这里。
So I've come down off of my high horse because it's such a huge thing. And I think I underestimated, probably, how huge it was. I had to really humble myself and be OK with people helping me. I'd get, like, two hours a night of sleep. So I just needed help.
所以我已经从高姿态上下来了，因为这是一件太大的事。我想我低估了它有多重大。我不得不放下身段，接受人们对我的帮助。我一晚只能睡两个小时。所以我真的需要帮助。
[BABY FUSSES]
[婴儿哭闹声]
That's him. His pacifier came out.
那是他。奶嘴掉了。
[BABY CRIES]
[婴儿哭声]
The baby wakes up while we're talking, Cole Anthony. He's six days old.
在我们谈话时，孩子醒了，科尔·安东尼（Cole Anthony）。他六天大。
For months, I've been thinking about Taylor and wondering about two things. Would she let people in once she had the baby? And also this question.
几个月来，我一直想着泰勒，并在思考两件事。她生下孩子后会接受别人的帮助吗？以及这个问题。
If these abortion laws were not in effect, if Roe had not been overturned, do you think you would have this baby now?
如果这些堕胎法律没有生效，如果“罗案”没有被推翻，你觉得你现在还会有这个孩子吗？
No.
不会。
Wow. How does that make you feel?
哇。那让你有什么感觉？
It makes me feel bad. It makes me feel bad. But I know for a fact that I've spent so much money on this kid, I've had so much anguish, I've lost relationships. I had to switch jobs. My body has changed. My mind has changed.
让我感觉很糟。感觉很糟。但我很清楚，为了这个孩子我花了很多钱，经历了这么多痛苦，失去了这么多关系。我不得不换工作。我的身体变了。我的心理也变了。
I underestimated what I would have to sacrifice to totally go through with it. And I feel like, although my baby is perfect, just because I have my baby doesn't mean that I'm happy that Roe versus Wade got changed. Because my life is never going to be the same. And I don't like that there's a piece of it that was impacted by a force that wasn't myself.
我低估了为了完全走下去我必须做出的牺牲。我感觉，虽然我的孩子很完美，但这并不意味着我因为“罗诉韦德案”的改变而感到快乐。因为我的人生再也回不去了。我不喜欢它受影响的那部分是由一个我不受自己掌控的力量所影响的。
Like, if I just decided to do it, have a baby, it'd be one thing. But to know that any part of it was challenged by some outside force, it's so messed up. And although right now everything's happy, giggles, newborn stage, this is my life now-- my whole life, not just 18 years. But this is just-- things are really going to change.
比如，如果是我自己决定要个孩子，那是一回事。但知道其中的任何一部分是被某种外部力量挑战，这太糟糕了。虽然现在一切都很开心，新生儿阶段，这是我的人生——不仅仅是18年，而是我的整个人生。事情真的要变了。
There will be some moment, probably soon, when we'll all just get used to the idea that people travel hundreds of miles and cross state lines to get abortions. That'll just seem normal, if it doesn't already. It'll seem normal that people have second-trimester abortions at home, that some people will panic and not know what to do with the fetal tissue, or feel too scared to seek medical attention. At some point in the future, that fear will not be remarkable.
也许很快会有那么一个时刻，我们都会习惯这样一个想法：人们为了堕胎不惜跨越数百英里、跨越州界。那将变得很平常，如果现在还不算平常的话。人们在家进行孕中期堕胎、有些人惊慌失措不知如何处理胎儿组织或因为害怕而不敢寻求医疗护理，这些在未来都会变得很正常。在未来的某个时刻，这种恐惧将不再值得大惊小怪。
And we will also get used to this notion that, for many people, if you get pregnant in a state where abortion is banned and you do not want a baby, you may still wind up with one. We are rapidly moving into that future, where all of this is normal, which means right now may be the last time we can truly feel how much has changed. For the people who wanted abortions nine months ago, the gap between what was and what is is very clear.
我们也将习惯这样一个观念：对于很多人来说，如果你在一个禁止堕胎的州怀孕了，而你又不想要个孩子，你最终可能还是会有一个。我们正在迅速迈向那个未来，在那里这一切都是正常的，这意味着此时此刻可能是我们最后一次能真正感受到世界发生了多大的变化。对于那些九个月前想要堕胎的人来说，“过去”和“现在”之间的鸿沟非常清晰。
Caroline Kitchener, she's a reporter at the Washington Post.
卡罗琳·基奇纳，她是《华盛顿邮报》的记者。
["TWO ROADS" BY VALERIE JUNE]
["两条路" 瓦莱丽·琼]
Well, today's program was produced by Chana Joffe-Walt and Valerie Kipnis and edited by Laura Starcheski. The people who put our program together today include Jane Ackermann, Elna Baker, Sean Cole, Michal Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Cassie Howley, Miki Meek, Alaa Mostafa, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
今天节目的制作人是Chana Joffe-Walt和Valerie Kipnis，由Laura Starcheski编辑。今天参与制作的人员包括Jane Ackermann, Elna Baker, Sean Cole, Michal Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Cassie Howley, Miki Meek, Alaa Mostafa, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney 和 Diane Wu。我们的执行主编是Sarah Abdurrahman。高级编辑是David Kestenbaum。执行编辑是Emanuele Berry。
Special thanks today to Peter Wallsten, Kainaz Amaria, Ali Block, "The Nocturnists" podcast, Kate Cole from The Northwest Abortion Access Fund, Elizabeth Nash, and Robert Marshall. Original music for today's show by Christina Courtin and Matt McGinley. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder Mr. Torey Malatia. He remembers when the Lord spake unto him-- which, judging from what happened to Abraham and Noah and Lot, does not always usually work out so great. Torey says God was like--
特别感谢Peter Wallsten, Kainaz Amaria, Ali Block，《夜班医生》播客，来自西北堕胎援助基金的Kate Cole，Elizabeth Nash和Robert Marshall。今天节目的原创音乐由Christina Courtin和Matt McGinley创作。《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交换中心）提供给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生。他还记得主与他说话的时刻——不过从亚伯拉罕、诺亚和罗得的经历来看，情况并不总是有那么好。Torey说，神当时问——
Hey what you doing? And I was like, oh, dear god.
嘿，你在干嘛？我说，噢，天哪。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
["TWO ROADS" BY VALERIE JUNE]
["两条路" 瓦莱丽·琼]